i've received a problem from bradley i
don't know his last name i'm assuming
it's a he i don't know where he lives
but the problem he gave is interesting
and i don't think i've covered this
before so i think it's worth covering so
the problem if i read his note properly
is this
3
sine
squared of x
is equal to 1 plus cosine of x
so at first cut this seems like a
difficult problem how do i you can't
solve for x you would have arc sines and
the square roots and cosines et cetera
et cetera so the way i approach this is
any time that you know if i see a cosine
x year but then i see a sine squared x
here
i start thinking of what trig identities
are at my disposal
and what trig identities involve a sine
squared x well the most basic trig
identity that comes out of the unit
circle definition of trig functions is
that sine squared x
plus cosine squared x
is equal to 1. and that's comes out of
the fact that the equation of a circle
is x squared plus y squared is equal to
the radius squared but if the unit
circle is equal to 1 squared but anyway
hopefully you have this memorized if
you've already been watching the trig
videos so what does sine squared x equal
well let's solve for it so sine squared
x
sine squared x is equal to 1 minus
cosine
squared x
right so we could substitute this term
right here
with this and what does that get us well
we're just playing around at this point
but at least at that that way everything
is in terms of cosine of x
so let's do that let's substitute so we
get 3
times sine squared of x we just showed
that sine squared of x is the same thing
as 1 minus cosine squared of x
1 minus
cosine squared of x
is equal to 1 plus cosine
of x we can simplify a little bit
3
minus 3 cosine squared of x
is equal to 1
plus
cosine of x
i don't know just just for kicks let's
put everything onto the right side of
the equation
and you'll see it wasn't just for kicks
0 right i'm just going is equal to let's
put this on to the right side
3
cosine squared
x
and then c
we have to subtract 3 from this side
well let's just write the cosine x first
plus cosine x
and then 1 minus 3 is minus 2. all right
let's make sure i didn't make a careless
mistake we had negative 3 here we added
3 cosine x 3 cosine squared x to both
sides right we subtracted 3 from both
sides minus 2 and then this cosine x is
this cosine x
now what can we do
well this is where it gets interesting
because this looks an awful lot like a
quadratic equation except for the fact
that
instead of having you know
a
you know a
ax squared plus bx plus c we have
a cosine squared x so we instead of just
having an x squared we have a whole
cosine of x squared so what do i mean by
that let me make a substitution and then
i think it'll all it'll all become
clear to you let's make the substitution
that
a and i'm just picking the letter a
arbitrarily is equal to cosine
of x
so if we were to take the cosine axis
and this and replace it with a what do
we get and i'm just going to switch it
around so i'm going to put the 0 on that
side equals 0.
so we get 3 well cosine squared x that's
the same thing as cosine of x squared
right
so we get 3
a squared
plus
a
minus 2
is equal
to zero
well now we have a pure quadratic and we
can solve it using the quadratic
equation
so what's what's the quadratic equation
let me write it up here
negative b plus or minus the square root
of b squared minus 4ac
all of that over 2a so what are the
roots of this equation well what's minus
and remember this a is different than
this a maybe i shouldn't have used an a
as a letter but these a b and c and the
quadratic equations represent the
coefficients so this is
a
b is
1 and c is just minus 2. so what are the
roots
of this
so the a's that solve this a can equal
and i know i confused you i could let me
actually let me write a different let's
make this uh
instead of a is equal to cosine x let me
say that
i don't know let me pick a good letter
that's not involved in the let me say d
so 3
d squared plus d
minus 2. so now the a b's and c's you
know are definitely the coefficients so
the solutions to this
are d
because i didn't want to use a b or c
d is equal to minus b well b is one
minus one and if this is completely
foreign to you you should review the
videos on the quadratic equation
minus
b squared well that's one squared
minus 4ac
so minus
4
times a times 3
times c
well c is minus 2 right so we get a that
minus cancels there we have a 2 there
all of that
over 2 times a a is 3 so we have it over
6. so this equals minus 1 plus or minus
the square root what is this 4 times 3
times 224
plus 125 oh this works out cleanly
over six
so that equals minus one plus or minus
five
over six
and so what are the roots the roots are
what's minus one minus five that's minus
six over six so it's minus one
what's the other one
minus one plus five is four
four over six is two thirds
so the solution to this equation let me
clear up some space hopefully
let me clear up
clear up some space here
let me see what was i doing
oh maybe i want to leave
i can get rid of this you know the
identity
and you also know the quadratic formula
and let's see actually let me get rid of
this to clear up a bunch bunch of space
i wanted to leave this here because this
showed how this turned into a quadratic
but instead of having it in terms of uh
instead of having in terms of just a
variable we have in terms of cosine of x
and then we made the substitution d is
equal to cosine of x anyway
so the solution to this equation is that
quadratic
is d
is equal to minus 1 or
two-thirds
right
but of course we made the substitution
long ago that d is equal to cosine of x
so the solution
to this equation in terms of x
is a solution to this equation cosine of
x
is equal to -1
or
cosine
of x is equal to two-thirds
well this one's easy right x is equal to
arc
cosine
arc cosine of minus one i always forget
there's two c's when you do r cosine
anyway
so what at what
degree or radian value does the cosine
of x is equal to -1
well it's at at pi right so x could
equal pi
which is also you know or 180 degrees
this one is uh not as easy i think i
will
have to use a calculator for this unless
i'm
whoops so you may not realize it
but google is actually a calculator
and a far more advanced calculator than
most
so we could use google to figure out the
arc cosine of two thirds let's do that
arc cosine i don't know if i'm
explaining it right
of two over three
google tells us
google tells us that it's 0.841
and a bunch of numbers
so
x
is equal to arc
cosine of two over three so x is equal
to
point
eight four
one oh six
let's see if they work let's well you
know just for fun let's just see let's
just see if this one works let's see if
we substitute pi
into this equation we get the correct
answer
well what's sine of pi
let me let me erase all of this just so
we can check it i'm only going to check
pi the 2.84 i don't know that's messy
but you can do that in your own time
so let's check pi
x equals no that's not what i wanted to
do
so what is let's make sure this works
with pi 3
sine squared of pi
is equal to 1 plus cosine
of pi
well what's sine of pi this is equal to
3 sine of pi pi
squared
is equal to one plus cosine of pi
well sine of pi is zero right the y
value when you go 180 degrees is zero so
this is zero
and what's cosine of pi cosine of pi is
negative 1. so 1 plus minus 1. well this
is true
so pi worked in that equation i think if
you substitute that
0.841068 whatever you would also find
that that works so thanks bradley for
sending this i thought this was a neat
problem because it looks like a
trigonometry and it was trigonometry but
yet a little bit of identities and you
have to recognize it as a quadratic
equation
i will see you in a future video